that's a true story you think you'll
ever get married
um
do you want to get married
well sure you know
but you know people go right yeah why
don't you have kids i go
well because i'm a man
but now you see it used to be you need a
woman to have children but if you say
that now
it's it's wrong you know dave chappelle
got a lot of trouble for saying only
women can have children
uh do you want children alone do you
want to burst i want him a lot
you're going to have to say well i
thought only a woman could birth a child
but apparently it's changed right no
yes no no you know that's the wrong hole
no listen
there's a uh
a transgender man in england and he gave
birth to a child okay all right
he said he wanted to be on the birth
certificate listed as the father
and it went to court and the judge said
no you can't be the father only women
can have children
and the transgender man said well when a
lot more men have babies people will
understand
but you can adopt or
have a surrogate and have children if
you want so you don't want a wife you
want a child
what what did i say
what she's staring at and would you like
another grandchild
howie oh my gosh she's looking at me
like i'll have your kid
you are married all right i'm done go in
the other room and talk it over with
your husband you looked at me
like would you like to have a child
because every time i open my mouth like
she goes 30 minutes and this whole thing
your dog she looked at me and said you
could have a surrogate and her eyes went
like this
she could have a surrogate and she went
like this howie i'm not kidding
wow did you do that
i guess yes
this is more awkward for me yeah yeah i
know i feel like you're married i know
your husband
but howie here's the question okay would
you like another grandchild
yeah
yes
my brother also would like a child too
my uh alex is here my son is here your
brother would like a child yeah you
could talk to him about it well do you
want to be the surrogate for that no i
do not that's disgusting
alex what kind of would you be
interested in john lovitz putting it
into the wrong hole
i don't want to do that
but
can you get pregnant
no oh then i'm not interested
i don't understand where this is going
but you don't want a wife you just want
kids
well yeah like a white but you know it's
like it's like saying
you know
you have to find someone that like like
likes you back
yeah that's always the rule
have you ever been have you ever been
yeah you've gone out with a lot of
people in in your years ever been close
to getting married
yeah yeah you know yeah
i've had girlfriends for a long time
but i don't talk about my private life
howie
you know why why swiping because it's
private
oh lord jesus i've never heard that
concept before you don't want to talk
about your private light if i know no i
don't talk about it it's private
okay because it involves other people
you see
so now you're exposing their private
life you just talked about jamming a
hose into a a one other person that was
my life
and that was that was her 40 years ago
more right 43 years ago right
it's not too soon and i didn't say the
woman's name i don't remember her name
she's not she might if she hears this
she might go oh my god that was me
right
[Music]